I'm Chad Michael Murray and we're about
to play never have I ever
with Edgar ever never never have I ever
snapped a selfie with the Zoe dang Goran
Maison no I've never heard it snap
selfie
I don't think I snapped up oh yeah she
was in that selfie but I didn't snap it
but I was in a large selfie with machen
and a whole bunch of us farmy types
never have I ever had Riverdale fans
slide into my DMS I don't know I between
you and I if you notice I'm rarely ever
on social media forgive me but if you're
there hi it's nice to see you but I
never go on there when I do it's to say
hello and post and then move on never
have I ever worked out with KJ and
Charles you know what I got to be honest
I'm a little bummed out that I haven't I
didn't find out about this until the end
and I do think KJ actually invited me
the first day I came in but I was so
overwhelmed trying to remember
everybody's names and meet everybody
because high-caste
old cast here's Chad Chad whole cast but
I know I heard that they all train and
he trains with mark and total I would
like so I might just have to venture up
there again and make sure that that
happens have I ever shared a scene with
both matching and skeet how wouldn't you
like to know
no I haven't I ever been recognized on
the street as Edgar never not yet but
I've been asked if I'm a cult leader
before so that's close enough
have I ever wanted to move to the farm
never thought about it first time has
ever crossed my brain pan so um I've
wanted to move to a farm I liked forums
on my course and selling chickens but no
never no farms for me have I ever felt
overwhelmed by the power of the
Riverdale
fandom no no no I embrace you guys I
love you guys I think you guys are
absolutely incredible and I know that
the cast that has been there since day
one I know that they appreciate every
single one of them I hear about it all
the time because you guys are awesome
you're the reason they're there have I
ever been weirded out that I'm now
playing a parent on the CW so whoever
asked this question you trying to date
me here when you trying to make me yell
make me feel a little old
getting not no not yes in the middle
it's interesting I started when I was 19
on Gilmore Girls and 20 on Dawson's and
I turned 21 when I started Xuan One Tree
Hill so for me it's it's incredibly
surreal to be a 37 year old man who has
kids now playing a father on Riverdale
it's incredibly cyclical and very cool
it's blows my mind now if there was a
vanilla milkshake in this you would also
know that that's probably my favorite
dessert tree I love a good vanilla
milkshake and that concludes our never
have I ever
with Edgar ever never featuring okay